this is a production of cornell
university
okay good thank casey for that wonderful
introduction it's really
a bit emotional when i get to this
invitation invitation it's a great honor
to be invited by your alma mater
and
i remember last time i gave a seminar in
that room was
for my big exam
and for my dissertation
and that was 17 years ago
so i think by that order probably i can
consider this as my c
exam and
okay so today i'm going to oh yes i want
to thank
uh
cassie
and
[Music]
gary and also gillian for giving me this
opportunity
that's okay so today i'm going to talk
about the genetic diversity of ergo
fungi at the species and the population
level and also in terms of
production of ergo alkaloids
so i'm going to give a quick historical
review of ergo taxonomy in pre-molecular
era and also molecular error
and then showcase a bit research results
from our population level study and
towards the end i want also introduce
some research we collaborated with other
labs in terms of the variation of ergo
alkali production and also at the gene
gene level
so before i start i like to give a quick
life cycle go through the quick life
cycle and so that everybody gets a big
background so the the black greens on
this broom grass can you see my my
like a mouse movie
yeah we can okay that's good okay so
these black greens are the resting body
sorry
this black green are the resting body of
the fungus the fungus we call the ergo
fungus and
and they they during the fall they will
drop on the ground and over winter and
next spring they will germinate produce
these drumstick like little structures
their sexual reproducing structure and
the inside of this big head
are the
the sexual
reproducing proto protocols which are
asco
spores arranged in a special order and
when the time comes and they will
disperse into the air and carried by the
wind to infect a flower specifically
only the flour of grasses or cereal
crops
and the germinated support the high fee
will keep growing towards the bottom of
the ovary and then interestingly they
will travel back
and not further to the plant but travel
back grow inside of this ovary and keep
keep growing and develop
and eventually eventually the seed
the space within the seed and all food
filled with the
asexual sports canadia and wrapped with
honeydew and those honeydew will ooze
out
and get a speak stick on the insect legs
and when the insect
fly onto another plant another plant
gets infected and this cycle will repeat
during the planting and the flowering
season
and
towards the end of the season the inside
of the seed will be fully packed with
macelia
and the masala will be
hardened and also pigmented and become
like this
resting body and or ergot
and then the cycle will repeat again
so ergot the according to the literature
the earliest record of
ergot
it's in this german book if
that's the earliest that i can trace out
maybe gary or he had more information
but anyway for in this
in this literature they called this uh
recorded regard as long black nails
between rice
and between rye grains and all due at
that time
they all considered urgot as a abnormal
grains so there were all kinds of
hypotheses
one hypothesis said that they were sunk
baked grains
or successive excessive formation of sap
or just a simply mutation of greens
until 1771
joe fry a
french pharmacist
considered urgot actually a separate
plant from its host plant and remember
at that time earth plant uh fung fungi
were considered as a plant
and about 40 years later diegando
agreed his hypothesis and assigned a
name to ergot sacrosium clavis
and another 40 years later atlas
discovered the sexual stage of ergot
and he erected a genus
as claviceps and also he considered the
species he discovered is a same species
with uh with the one freeze
uh called a name called severia purpurea
that's why he called this
name
he renamed the fungus as a clavice
purpurea
and also noted
the candles circular ocean clovers is
the synonym of
the
clarice purpurea the fungus he's working
on and in addition he also recognized
two other species
and see microcephala and see nigricans
and based on the morphology and the
biology such as c microcephala
it produces this very as the error shown
here very long flexural
stipes and a very soft little head
and also biologically microcephaly the
sclerosis can germinate immediately on
the
crop and the sucralose
do not does not need to drop on the
ground and after the freeze treatment
and germinate again and which is most of
the species will need that
and in terms of negligence in
agriculture this is on the sieges and
the morphologically according to tulasa
the parasitisia dis
arranged more distantly
than other species
and after tolasca
ergo species were described here and
there
and this is the list i summarized from
index fungal room and
microbank and i i might missed a few but
i will say in overall it's not a long
list
and also a side note here the red the
the taxa in species in red font were
classified to other
uh general based on molecular taxonomy
later
and until uh 1940s 1940 to 1950s
london from australia hated extensive
work on urgot
he uh
described some new species from
australia and also evaluated 25
existing species and in addition he also
evaluated the
usefulness of morphological characters
such as
according to him the shape the shape and
the color of sclerosia are informative
but not the size
and and in terms of stomata he thinks
the color and the skype
the color of stipe and the capitula are
informative but not the length of the
type he said he said the the lens will
keep growing when the when the stomata
uh growing mature so it's not very
informative and also he did say the
placement of paresthesia is informative
and also he mentioned in his
dissertation some specific characters
such as a color around the base of a
capitula a white ring or lose high fee
around the capitula unfortunately he
didn't show any picture of those
characters and we will just have to pay
attention to that when we do our
taxonomy
and
and also in terms of the canadian and
hey they agree that the shape and size
of canadia are different between species
however they are also variable within
species so it can be useful but to a
certain extent
lovelies in 19 between 1950 to 1970s did
more careful work in terms of the shape
and size of canadia
he started the
canadian from collected from 34 grasses
and
in in rosia rhodesia is a place nowadays
close to
equivalent to zimbabwe
and what he did is he randomly picked 25
spores and
grafted them with a special tool to
graft them
and outline them and separated
categorized them to certain groups
and then he was able to uh associate
six of the groups who speak already
described species such as this group two
see
past pali and you know six species and
and and also he
predicted there should be another seven
species
uh
in this area
and what's interesting is after
many years after many years several
species were described in
south africa the area close by
and it turned out the evaluation turns
out that they actually the canadians
did match with his prediction
and it's kind of amazing
and another name uh people can encounter
when you study taxonomy of urgot is
tanda
and from japan he is a person
you know focused on varieties he did
describe a few species but
characterized a whole
array of varieties
and i did based on very very careful
studies such as this one i showed a
plate from his publication i studied the
shape size of the sacrosia and astrometa
parasitic canadian shape and the size
and even the honeydew
sugar content and alkaloid content
did very compel very detailed comparison
of the urgot from different hosts
and the one from valarie volaris he did
noted that this one had
a significantly larger canadian
but he was not convinced it's a new
species he just called it a variety like
super perio variety followed this and
actually and based on modern
molecular taxonomy this turned out to be
a new species and described by later by
puzzle tower group called humidifier
and in the same ways many of his
varieties need need evaluated some of
them might represent a new species some
may be just at variety level
and the sugar content and the usefulness
for taxonomy was started by mower and
hancock in 1975
and they were able to recognize a few
taxonomy
groups and
they have different content such as the
group or group a the species in group a
are rich in monosaccharides
however in the species in group 2 are
rich in
sugar
alcohol and also there are also some
species just mixed with
uh like he called intermediate
and compared to sugar content
most studies were attracted for ergo
content study because of their
significant impact to
agriculture because they are toxic right
and also because of their pharmaceutical
potentials as i indicated the color
coded here like different species
contain a different sets of
ergo alkaloid and i will talk about
today's topic later in my presentation
so move on to molecular error
the group in czech republic
led by puzzle torah did a
pioneer work for ergo taxonomy he they
were able to characterize the
different species with wrapped marker
and its one markers
and as i showed the picture here
different species have diff showed
different profiles
and in addition they also
uh developed this new
media high high sugar content media they
call the t2 media and usually clariceps
on the pda media will grow very fluffy
and white and difficult to tell apart
the species however on this media you
can see
different species will grow more compact
and show different
texture and also different hint of
colors which can be used for
differentiated species
and and also on this media the claviceps
can
tend to produce more
canadia
and this gave them opportunity to
observe more characteristics of the
canadian and such as the presence or
absence of macros canadian as i show
picture on the left and this oval shaped
of a shape just small size canadian
sorry
another
presence and absence and also the shape
can be different between different
species
and another feature is
they called secondary canadian and what
happened is the canadian when the
canadian
land on the media they will start to
germinate and produce germ tubes and the
germ tube will produce another canadian
another canadian can produce germ tube
and produce another canadian again so
they call that micro cycle and the
different species these times of micro
cycle different some species just want
some species maybe two or three times
and the
use
multi-gene phylogeny to differentiate
clavicle species started with a u.s
group
and they were able to
separate it separate the
census c uh prepares censulato into
three groups and these three groups are
actually called
consistent with the three chemo races uh
identified by potato group and
and
and they also indicated that these three
groups are associated with ecological
niches indicating a kind of ecological
speciation
until a 2015
puzzle tower group
conducted a formal taxonomy treatment
for those three groups
and gave them gave each of them a name
and in addition they also found the
third lineage
and third lineage and they named it it
see a rudinis
and as a
side note here this concept of
arrowdenis is equivalent to
c macrocephala a tolerance concept
however the type of c microcephaly had
some issue
so they renamed instead they renamed the
fungus as arudines arudinis and if you
if you are interested anybody interested
in and in the details and can look look
there this publication and i'm not going
to too much detail and for this for this
clade for the torah group called it c
humidifier basically it is the same tax
they considered it's the same taxa with
the one
tanda described as the sea purple real
variety folaridis
and
what's interesting is i'll carry a
you know follow-up study just recently
between me and
eg and also miroslav we we discovered
that actually the
the species
these species this clade actually
is different clay different species with
the uh tanda's variety and
it's it's a bit complicated because of
the type the type specimen the the
designation of this type had some issue
and so
in a short word this
taxa right now correct the name we gave
it correct gave it a new name called c
bowery ansys and the real sikh
humidifier actually is restricted in
japan
and yeah if you for more detail you can
look into this this publication and it's
going to publish
soon next week this is the preliminary
pdf file
and
another another uh advance in the in
class the classic uh
in the taxonomy of kala reception is
another comprehensive multi-gene
phylogenetic analysis by this apostolate
group led by a miroslav cholaria and and
yeah and
it's kind of said notes that
the
uh puzzle tova doctor torah passed away
and i think just before the 20
after 2015 paper published around that
time
so it's kind of very sad and
uh miroslav the guy stands here he is a
lead right now
leave that group
and in this paper they separated the
clavis the genus claviceps into four
sections
and and also studied the
the alkaloid production and the host
correlation
and very comprehensive
excellent work
and also
in the in a supplementary table and they
were kind of shy and they listed all the
existing species names and they kind of
gave a preliminary evaluation of those
names whether it's valid or or not valid
it's set a very good foundation for a
monograph
but unfortunately it's in a supplement
to table and
i
if you don't pay attention you barely
notice that
and here in canada
in
our national mycological herbarium there
are about 700 calorie subs species and
90 percent of them labeled as
claviceps poopery
and
in addition there are a few more species
described
in record i think a part of the reason
probably because uh clarisse has never
been seriously studied by the
taxonomist in canada
and that's why since 2016 my lab started
working on
this uh genetic diversity of this
species in canada
and we with the help of
all the friends and the colleagues and
organizations and we got a big
uh data got a big collection from the
agriculture and the non-agricultural
area
and
we did a multi-gene phylogeny this
yeah this is a metis multi-gene
phylogeny and on these phylogeny uh
phallogenetic trees all the three
species discovered by
potato group recovered here you can see
spatina
and narutinisi and in addition there are
also four other lineages stand out and
they represented a new lineage and we
described them as a species such as this
one is closely related with spatina with
name
we rename we named it at rippy cola
it's it was collected like around the
river banks and say
and sand use and lake banks and like a
semi wet area habitat and it's quite
common and we collected a bunch of
species from quebec from alberta from
different areas many manitoba from
different areas
and this one we got only two collections
actually
on these three only one collection later
on we collected another collection and
this one was collected from newfoundland
from salt marsh
and
it is on agrostates and the character of
this species you can see on this uh
culture petri dish is a cultural place
and they produce a very very compact
canadian i don't know the colony and and
you can see also with this root system
like the structure it's very unique from
others
and two other species seek by senses
collected from quebec
and
characterized by this oval shaped
canadian and it's not a micro canadian
it's bigger than micro canadia
and sea occidentalis
is also very interesting we only have
the culture
from our culture collection
and the originally the specimen was
collected in alberta in the 1950s and i
i
asked my like a friends and colleagues
to go back to the collection location uh
original location try to collect it
again and we we were not able to collect
it so far so hopefully we we can just
keep watching it and collect it but
meanwhile it also tells us how important
our
cultural collection is
so there might
there might be some new species embedded
there
so add to the new species we described
this updated up
up-to-date list in canada
and i believe there are more new species
and waiting to discover for discovery
and so now i
i'm going to go to talk a little about
our population level study
and
so let's go back to this big phylogeny
and a question would
ask is for this big clade and it's
basically a bush here and we will ask
is it truly just a bush because of the
mixed population because of the uh
you know
the recombination frequent recombination
and between the species so the the
exchange of genetic material that's why
there is no separation or whether there
are actually some kind of
subdivision
and
for these for that fellow genetic could
tree
and the strict phallogenetic analysis
and
it's based on the assumption
the of the relationships among the taxa
are tree shaped up by
bifurcate and it's not good
for the inferring the relationship among
the taxa with the horizontal gene
exchange
and
instead a network based analytical tools
and and recently
developed
it you know take take consideration of
that
reticulated relationship and will be
better for that system so we with that
in our mind we looked into some of those
kind of analytical
method
so we analyzed the same data
the big clade with the multigen
data with a split tree
so
split tree basically
separated
146 hyper types
from
156 sample
into three different clades
yeah as i show here this network and
she says then for genetic cluster and tc
you can see tc1 is more deeply separated
from gc2 and the gc3 and the tc2 and htc
3 look like more close more close
and it's kind of nice to see a pattern
but we were wondering whether this is a
consistent pattern or just a coincidence
so to confirm that we looked into other
methods such as beast
and also the principal coordinate
analysis and
from this they should graph
beast and also this this graph and you
can all tell gc1 is
is
more deeply more distantly separated
from gc2 and gc3
tc2 and gc3 there is a little bit
intermingle and probably indicate their
recent
separation or maybe just
maybe just an error and you know we
don't know
and
and we also did some population
uh
statistic tests and
so
i i don't have you don't need to
understand each of these numbers values
indicate but basically these values
indicate there are very strong
suggestion of
population subdivision
and with
with limited
gene flow among the populations
and with that and we we also ask a
question whether this separation
correlated with the host
with the geographic
areas and so we mapped those different
genotype all the samples
on this map
and you can see it's not correlated with
the geographic location we separated the
geographic like west canada east canada
and west u.s each of these regions and
contain the three genetic clusters and
this is the graph
and the similar story although with
different uh portion of
of different genetic clusters
and
in addition then we ask whether it's
correlated with host
and we separated the host also to three
groups
like a crop
ttc mainly you know treated sea crops
and non-treated tea crops animals
this
and also broomy
and by this separation
you can also see on these three
crop
these three host groups
also
contain each of those three genetic
clusters which with slightly with
different proportions but i i think a
home message
is
there are three then
sub-populations between canada and the
western u.s however
those sub-division is not
strictly correlated with the geographic
location or the host
separation
and here i would like to acknowledge my
technician paravash shukuhi and also
the co-op students and they developed
all this data and students come and go
and they
learn the techniques but meanwhile also
have contributed on the
to the data development
so now i like to switch
geotalk about to the variations in terms
of er called alkaloid production and
also at the gene level
now erica alkaloids are mycotoxin
contained in
mainly mainly in ergo
ergo bodies
and the
by the complexity they were classified
into different classes as i showed here
in this graph
they include the simple clarins as
these green colors like channel chlorine
agrochronic element climbing produced in
early steps of the pathway
and also the ergopeptides the most
complex
alkaloids produced at the end at the end
product and in between there are
dihydroalkaloids and
emits
so since the
ergo acolyte was isolated i think it's
1950s and for the first time there are
more and more
uh
alkaloids
compounds were isolated from different
species with different techniques there
there are several good review papers as
i listed here and if you're interested
you can always look into these
references
so
here i'm i'm not going to like
systematically go review all this i will
just
like highlight a few point research
results and from our
collaborative work
and indeed to show
the variations of ergo alkaloid
production at a different taxonomy level
and also at the gene level
at section level
and as indicated by pichova 2018
and the section pusili c-section
proceeding mainly produce the simple
clarins
and
and the maximum some intermediate
intermediate
alkaloids
and
and also past parallel section path
parallel is also like some simple and
intermediate ones the
complex ergo peptides is exclusively
produced by section claviceps
and
four sections c
citrine
for
for species
citrine and the only number in section
citrine
does not produce any
ergo alkaloid
that's the section level
so for the species uh
in the section and clavice insection
claviceps they may contain different
sets of peptide
such as the new species we described
uh c rippy cola uh mainly
mainly contained ago kreptin and and
it's epimers for sickbest senses in
addition ergocryptin also has ergosyn
and uh
but for c para humidifier
uh it's mainly composed by ergo crest
time and
so uh dave dave over is our mycologist
but also a chemist and
hey
how
our
our chemistry related work is conducted
in his lab
and so if you have any questions in
terms of chemistries you can contact him
with this email
and
another study by the
norwegian
norwegian group they also confirmed the
ergo profile ocular profile not only
ergo pro alkaloid but also other indoor
alkaloids profile among these three
three species are different
and we also looked into the
intra-specific variation uh master
student
carmen did they did an experiment
and with
uh she's also dave's student but with
his collaboration with team manzie uh
research scientist yi modern research
center plant pathologist and also my lab
and what we did is we selected some
isolates eight athletes of purple
inoculated them on
four different crops
and then when the crop cereal when the
greens mature we harvested the sclerosia
and then separate the sclerosis to two
parts one part used for profile of
alkaloids and another or one part for
the half for the
identity for confirm their identity and
another file however for the profile or
acrylic profile and this is the result
on the left
is uh
from untargeted
metabolic profile and you can clearly
see
the
this is from wheat the circulation from
wheat you can clearly see there
separated to two classes the red and
blue and the same pattern
is consistent
from
uh for the sclerosia from other hosts
of other three hosts
and the on the right is a ergo alkaloid
ergo alkaloid profile
and
on you you can also look look at the
pattern and it's very clear
the right this column the red columns
are
the class 1 and the blue is
class 2 and you see they they have
different patterns
of mass features
notably this in these boxes you see some
mass features only presented in class 2
but some only in class 1
and if and if you want to know more
detail
refer to this publication
so
another question we asked you know
remember for the population we
we found this subdivision and we can
consider tc1tc3
as one big population we were wondering
whether this subdivision actually
correlated
somehow consistent with these chemo
classes
and unfortunately the result is the
answer is no and
[Music]
it would be interesting to understand
what are why is now and what are the
mechanism underneath this
is this separation
and in order to understand the variation
at the gene level and also what what
kind of mechanism at the gene level
might result to the separation of the
chemo classes and even also the
population classification and we
initiated our our genome project with
collaboration with miroslav czech
republican group and kirk browders
and he he was a professor in state
university colorado
and but now he's in usda
and also with our
afc bio mob work package 2 is a part of
a big project
like this work package led by jeremy uh
our mycologist in our group
and we totally we sequenced the 53
illumina
genomes with illumina platform and also
a few with nanopore
and steel steel is a student of kirk and
he focused on comparative genomics
and we focused on the divergence of each
genes
and here i will just only focus talk
about these east genes wendy is our
bioinformatician helped with the
pipeline
and of the assembling and the erg and
the
cluster gene cluster extraction and dr
new yin also
supervised
wendy and help us and he's also a
research scientist
our mycologist
so uh based on pre previous study ergo
alkaloid um
in claviceps in claviceps purpurea there
are 12 genes and including three rps
genes of lps a
b and c lpsa had two copies and they are
super long
and
it's not possible
based on illumina sequences to grab the
whole
whole gene so that is why we did a
nanopore
and but for for other 11 genes we were
able to
extract them from illumina sequence
and this is the results from the
illumina sequence
and it's kind of busy
the take-home message yeah this is a
different species of
uh
the graphic cells and this the the um
from cross is a different genes
and
basically the take-home message is
between species and we found the gene
number and a gene copy polymorphism
and
and also for the section in section
clariceps
um it's more consistent
in terms of gene copper relatively
consistent
in terms of gene number and a gene copy
for priscilla
is small variable such as sea africana
we detected eight genes but maximum is
none
and this actually is very nicely
correlated with their production and
this is a reminder from the petrova
paper and on this tree you can see
maximize produce none
but africana produce
some
uh
you know dehydrate alkaline and even
some you know simple alkaloids produce
some but also but in other cases it's
not that consistent
such as priscilla and soji we detected
eight to nine genes for priscilla most
of the genes are kind of non-functioning
look like a non-functioning so it's
understandable but for soji
most of the genes look functioning
and however in this
in their chat and
no ergo ocular production is detected
and this is also worth to
uh you know more investigation
this is a within species
between the
streams among the strains
all the other strains
the variation among the strains
basically
as some strains contain the second copay
of ece is f
or even third copy of ezif and also a
few strands doesn't have the second copy
is is h
and
in terms of the gene
gene copy polymorphism and we also
looked into the
dna sequence variation
and
across the different genes
and we looked at the
gene diversity and gene divergence
across the different genes and what
we've we evaluated by three parameters
nucleotide diversity and tree-based
diversity and divergence from center of
a tree
and so what we found very interesting is
the genes in early and
late
step of pathways
are more diverse of that
have more diversity
than
the genes in the center
and this is very interesting because
it's called
kind of
resemble this
uh
model called the hourglass model in
antarctic
and
this antarctic
hourglass model was
proposed in
1990s and they indicated that one fish
my theaters
developed on the early and
later stages are more diversions and
not in the center
and
so and this hypothetically this model
there there has been a
heated debate
and between this model and also other
models they are also early conservative
model in indicated the early step should
be more conserved the later steps are
more diverged and and also there are
also other models i'm not going detail
and
now
and so and there are women's debate
between which model is you know it's
got more evidence
and recently some genomic
work
did provided more evidence for this
hourglass model
and our question here is
this model with this shape we found in
this ergo alkali pathway and we were
wondering whether it is just a
coincidence
or it actually tells something and we
were also wondering whether it
exists in other metabolic pathway
and what are the mechanisms
behind this
and
gilliam probably can tell us more about
today's weather it's
sorry
oh it's almost ready right sorry
okay
and okay i'm almost done
and so uh yeah this is the last slide
the
as i told as i said before the orga uh
the
18 is super long and we can't grab the
whole
whole uh
whole sequence so that's why we did nano
per sequence and we include for a few
strands include one representative from
each of the chemotype
and tom
from also from dave's lab he
gra he used this pipeline and grabbed
the whole
cluster from this strains and did the
comparison and through the comparison he
found the
higher levels of polymorphism around the
lpsa regions you can see the red lines
are more elevated than other places and
also he also observed a stop coder
at the second c domain of class one the
string of class one and which might
indicate for the class one strings might
have only one functioning of lpsa
and another observation is the variation
here at the second domain of
a domain of
lpsa a1
and the
the sequences
predicted
an encode leucine or other branched
hydrophobic amino acid instead of
phenylalanine which is
other other species other
strains produced and this is
actually this observation talk nicely to
the ergo alkaloid
the separation of these two classes as
we indicated earlier in that graph
class one and class two and class one
had this branched amino acid in the
second domain but the class two has
affinity and
so another follow-up question would be
whether this is only this this sequence
of variation whether it's only in this
one single strand or also in other
strands and he went back to our illumina
sequence and only extracted this this
region only square this frog so he was
able to
extract that region and did alignment
and
enough phylogeny and based on this
phylogeny and the dna sequencer analysis
other students in this class a also had
the same feature and the same sequence
variation in code and lucian branch the
hydrophobic
so the collectively based on this
evidence
the
the variation
or sequence of variation at the second
domain of a domain of lps a1 and also
possibly
due to the
lack of the second to second copy of
lpsa might be the trigger of the
separate relation of the two classes
yeah that's all we i have to say i just
want to reiterate a few the few points i
i you know the take-home message from
each of the
of the topics for for clavis taxonomy of
collapse in pre-molecular era the
species were described by mythology of
circular rocias comata canadia sugar
content and ea production and there were
there were 67 named species and the
worth need to
re-evaluate it based on molecular
taxonomy and for the molecular error
and claviceps the genus was separated
into four sections
and the clarissa propriocensulato
was separated into several fellow
genetic species and and
the molecule based on
monograph is needed
for the
populations between
canada and the west u.s
the three three sub-populations however
the subdivision is not associated with
geographic or host separation and we
don't know the rate
reason yet
and
so in terms of the variation of organ
alkaloid production is genes the
variation at
the variation is gene is production
exists between species between sections
species and strains and which are
associated with present absence of these
genes and also the variation in
dna sequences
so yes
and i i yeah without all this help from
our friends and all these people we
can't have any work done so i think i
just owe a big thank to all of them
on the
on the list and
so and
thank you
thank you for your attention
i hope i don't i did not over time too
much
that was great thank you very much mindy
thank you thank you so great to have you
sort of here i wish you were really here
um i'll open the floor for questions in
just a second um but i want to say that
we'll post in the chat right now a
meeting room for a 1 45
meeting with mindy and i and some other
people
right mindy
oh yeah okay yeah right so yeah 45 i'll
post a new zoom link and you're welcome
to hop on
okay
check for it in the chat that's a great
meeting
yeah um are there any questions for
mindy today
um mindy
yes um
remind me uh does
any of do any of the alkaloids have
effects on plants
has uh
uh you mean urgot you mean the urgot to
unplanned
uh
you know the sexual
sexual reproduction is certainly
predicted
right predicted in the urgot but where
they have sex on the planet
that's uh that's a
question
probably
probably the sexually producing sexual
initiation is already there and when
they drop on the ground and they
germinate and produce
you know
segregate
i would think maybe that's the case but
another piece of information i don't
know whether i answered the question but
another piece of information is
positive and they had a lot of classic
genetic study on this record and
they found the
even though heterozygosity
is not necessary for the reproduction of
our god but they found that
but it exists it's not necessarily
you know homozygous is also okay and
they also are observed and it can also
produce or got you know repeated the
life cycle but heterozygous also
happened
also present
and another information i don't know
another information is also very
interesting i i very interesting is for
the
biosciences
capacity one of the species i described
and we collected a few specimens
and one of the specimens and our first
isolation
is occupying senses
and when we second time when we isolate
again because that's
that culture kind of had some accident
lost we lost that culture and then i as
we go back to the urgot again to
separate
and we just never get consensus again we
always get
prepared
so there is an indication probably it's
just a small segregation small
section maybe
of the new genotype and it happened the
first time we isolated it and afterwards
we just navigated again but which also
indicated on that record there might be
hybrids
hybrids or even you know
sex
sexual reproduction in that and and also
even maybe hybrids between species
i'm wondering
i don't know
any comments
okay uh this is scary uh could you
remind me the graduate student study i
think that you talked about where they
took uh
a number of individual isolates coming
from different hosts but they were all
in the
in the purpurea uh sensory strictu
population if i remember right yes
that's right what was there most much uh
differential specificity virulence um
on the different hosts i know they came
from different hosts but when they
inoculate onto those four or five
uh
grass species was there uh was there
really much differentiation of the
population that way
i found uh
i i will just speculate
but if you want to know precise
but i will contact jim manzi you know
jim mansi right oh yeah
yeah you know him yeah he probably can
provide more
more information oh yes it reminded me
they had recently had a new publication
and studied the
host specificity and pathogenicity at
different level different levels so
there is
different levels of pathogenicity but i
am not not but it may not necessarily
show for each of those strengths
it's the general message that most of
these isolates in the sense restricted
group are kind of generalists in their
homes
yes yes yes
that's the thing that interests me the
most but
another little thing mindy i might just
mention to you uh we've had a chance in
the last few years to
interact uh with folks in the alltech
company they do a lot of extensive
mycotoxin screening i think they screen
for some 40 some mycotoxins and grains
and whatnot but one interesting thing
the last couple of years they've been
showing
[Music]
ergot alkaloids showing up in uh
corn silage which i find interesting
because as far as i know corn is not a
host for a claviceps but
my my hypothesis is that you know when
you take
cut corn for silage you're getting
pretty close to the ground
and and that they're probably uh
harvesting weedy grasses
that have ergot that are just growing
between the roads of corn but i don't
know
is would you have a different reaction
to that finding or uh that's very very
interesting i was looking for the
workout on corns
coins for a while but i never found it
but i know there is a species
there is a species on corn let me check
let me check maybe i don't have it here
because
yeah
there is a one i think it's a gigantic
never seen it that's really fascinating
but yeah it's very fascinating and again
here and and also people told me i
remember once i had a conference with
another lady and
i said i studied regard and she said she
found
in canada even in canada and i you know
during the summer i try to find them i
can't but
in some cases i found it's different to
tell whether you know already state
whether they are smart
whether they have some other record
i
yeah i don't know and yeah so there is a
species but it's very interesting and
maybe they can trace back
to the field
you know you you you found that your
colleague funded the
in the asylum right maybe we can trace
back to the field and see
can find some specimens
of
thank you very much enjoyed your seminar
you're very welcome thanks i hope
i hope
my talk is not
not to
well it overwhelm
overwhelming but in a very good way
that's an interesting system and i i
have one
question for you about i think you
mentioned when you were talking about
the honeydew
that it varies in its sugar content but
it also varies in its alkaloid content
and i was curious about that
if i have that right
you know i think of honeydew as the way
the fungus gets its asexual spores
dispersed by bugs
so why put alkaloids in there doesn't
that mess up the bug
oh
you're right i can't see actually
some recent study work indicated in the
honeydew there's no alkaloids
very very very very low very very low
i think i will say no
alkalis and there are there was also a
publication by the
canadian
green
commission
canadian queen commission there was a
group of scientists working on the
acolyte and they had a recent
publication compared
they even actually compared the honeydew
and also the
but in culture
in culture in honeydew no but in culture
sometimes some students can produce
and that is also the way the
pharmaceutical company they want it
right
they kind of use different uh methods a
different way to stimulate the fungus to
produce
alkaloids in my head i think of the
alkyl alkaloids as a sort of
protection for the sclerosis
is that how you think it works i think
so too
i think so too i i think you know uh
i always saw there was publication there
was some application but there are two
publications recently you know they they
indicated you know from our perspective
we think regard is a pathogen
because they are bad for us
and bad for the agriculture and
a way and for some species they are
had certain levels of certain levels of
pathogenicity and can lower the
production the yield but in most cases
actually
it can be called mutualism
they actually one one thing as you said
the alkaloid actually protects the
fungus from devour of
animals or the insects or that stuff
another way is the black color
black color they kind of
free
scare away
other people you know the black
they did research actually the the black
color actually
takes away their their enemies so in
that sense
a regard actually is a mutualism should
be
okay
i i will say that well what about so
there's one species you mentioned maybe
maximus that you didn't find any toxin
genes in oh
yes that's right that's right what's
that one got going on
yeah that's right i we don't find any
but i i honestly i don't have a lot of
experience with that species though
and i i think those are like a tropical
from
north
from south africa don't have a lot of
experience yeah i don't we don't find
any
uh we don't find any
accolade and then no jeans
it will be very interesting
yeah to look into it
it might be
of that yeah but yeah
i'm i'm wondering whether it's it's
actually not a regard
but it was uh but i think
the patrol paper did indicated other
yeah well are there other questions
today for mindy
otherwise
i'll remind you that we're meeting again
with mindy at 1 45 and you're welcome to
just join our
zoom group for a chat with her
informally
um
and i just want to end mindy by saying
i'm sorry it took us so long to invite
you back
but it sure is nice to see you
thank you so much in person sometime yes
sometimes thank you so much for inviting
me
it's great it's great you know even
though it's not a person to person this
is also great
yeah thanks
thank you all
thank you all for participating
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu